[ __ ] we got it in years this week
popular dinosauria game Ark survival
evolved was released on ps4 the $55
offering has arrived in the form of the
survivors pack which includes the base
game and the scorched earth expansion
that features new areas and Dragons
survival evolved was initially blocked
from releasing on the ps4 as it is still
in development but clearly Sony of
loosing their stance on that front
studio wildcard hath promised a constant
stream of updates between now and when
the complete version arrives in spring
of next year the dev of also kicked off
a double XP evolution event which will
extend until December 12 the ps4 version
includes exclusive content including a
bionic Giganotosaurus skin and semantics
or almost at for those of you opening
google the Giganotosaurus is indeed a
real dinosaur and it's thought to have
been one of the largest theropods
although the incompleteness of its
remains means they can't be sure if it
was indeed the larger isn't that
interesting if you can't wait to see a
group of plucky rebels steal some papers
up the space desk of Australia's Ben
Mendelsohn star wars battlefront rogue
one Scariff DLC is available now now the
DLC ads for maps set on the no doubt in
correctly pronounced tropical planet of
Scariff two new playable characters jinn
or so and the mechanic from the place
beyond the pines director Orson Critic
as well as new weapons and star cards
there is also a new multistage mode
called infiltration that features ground
and space-based combat along with the
free free x-wing VR mission for
PlayStation VR you can grab rogue lines
Scariff for star wars battlefront right
now if you have the ultimate edition or
the season pass or you can wait and pick
it up on its own on december twenty and
x-wing VR is free for all owners of star
wars battlefront on ps4 it's bridge
Final Fantasy 15 it's my favorite game
about instant noodles until the accuser
6 comes out anyway this week Hajime
tomorrow the game director announced a
bunch of new free updates that will be
coming for the game in the future Tabata
said on a square enix blog post that the
great reception of the game has allowed
the developer to expand their post
launch plans even further their early
plans are to enrich certain aspects of
the game with gameplay enhancements for
chapter 13 buffs to ring Magic among
other things after those updates come
out Square Enix will focus on the story
adding more scenes and sequences which
will give insight into characters in the
long term Tabata said the idea is to
make certain key characters beyond the
four protagonists playable at a new game
plus mode as well as items that
introduce new play styles like low-level
runs and god mode they're looking into
readability tweaks like font sizes and
finally they're looking to add real-time
content like new bosses with exclusive
rewards and limited time hunts count me
in now let's take a quick break to watch
this amazing cup noodle ad CK Caro mio
Caro Mussina reddish cargo Tory moscato
soaring a second almera East modellbau
moral code
shalini new company over 50 dooms latest
free update has arrived and it's making
changes some multiplayer you can now
play against AI controlled enemies
unfortunately the bots are currently
only included in the death match and
team deathmatch roads and they're
limited to the original slate of
multiplayer maps update 5 also
introduces a new multiplayer mode called
infernal run we're in two teams compete
to hold on to a ball and chuck it into
the enemy's goal although this is doom
so that ball is the squishy eyeball
obviously the level cap has also been
bumped up to a Shalon 11 and you can log
on now for double XP until December 12
for the full patch notes check out our
story on gamespot speaking of patch
notes we're now going to read you the
patch notes on Pokemon go trainers will
be able to transfer multiple Pokemon at
a time to Professor willow to use this
function press and hold on a Pokemon
Pokemon type icons have been added to
the gym battle approach and the gym
battle screen the total candy count for
your buddy Pokemon has been added to the
Buddy information screen the total
kilometers a buddy has walked has been
added to the information screen of each
Pokemon that has ever been your buddy
and minor text fixes this week on site
you can check out our coverage of the
Last Guardian see us tuck into
cooperative multiplayer in dead rising
for and enjoy the beautiful food of
Final Fantasy 15 with us Oh long gray
and that's all the stuff we wanted to
tell you that this week so thanks for
sticking with us again have an awesome
weekend as i will see you on Monday